we haven't seen each other in quite a
while I believe right like two weeks
yeah we got a lot to CCH you were in
Thailand I was in Thailand what were you
doing just catching with the family yeah
had a big family reunion and uh just
wanted to chill out in my house in
Thailand and catch up with some friends
as well and pretty much January is the
only month this year um that I'm going
to be able to travel back to Thailand I
think so I was like I got to take this
opportunity but I am pissed off because
I missed the big Geeks plus trip oh yeah
where all of the company went on this
great trip both of you [__] missed
out on it wait what he didn't go
either I didn't wait what you didn't
know I didn't go now wait you didn't
know I just didn't I had I had stuff
came up no I was busy I I I last minute
had to put together a gaming tournament
yeah he was he was too busy being a
streamer wait
what was that the the Apex tournament
yeah Apex came to me cuz they had a
collaboration with Final Fantasy yeah
yeah right H and I guess I don't know
how I guess you're the final fantasy guy
I don't know how it all came about and I
I don't know cuz I was literally asked
like last minute I don't know why they
were like well I guess maybe they had
like maybe some ad agencies a budget
left over or something yeah and I guess
there was like no one who knew both
games pretty well yeah but I I was
trying to think about it I was like I
don't think there's many streamers who
know Apex really well and know final cuz
it's just completely different audience
I guess I guess you've just got that one
little niche now see when you the dude
that knows Final Fantasy pretty well oh
he's he's completely two
oh [__] [__] he's completed more than me
Joey how many how many okay how many
[__] Gamers who play first person
shooters have completed like a final
fantasy all the way through that is true
not many I feel like at least not that's
the minimum requirement have you
finished at least one final fantasy I
think I think you'll be hardress only
Japanese
vtubers well I think that was maybe why
the collaboration came about cuz it was
like obviously I think to a lot of
people in the west they were like what
what what is it CL it is a weird CL they
asked me to put together a tournament
last minute uh and it like wasn't even
we were we were trying to get it all
done like it wasn't even confirmed until
like literally like two days before did
it go well yeah it went great it was a
fun tournament it worked out really well
and I think everyone had fun um got to
bring out some people who I wanted to
get involved in something for a while
yeah uh and I think people really
enjoyed it uh you got to make sure with
these kind of events that like how do
you make a game maybe people don't
really understand how do you make it
like easy to watch that's always a tough
part is Apex difficult to understand I
guess maybe to non Apex players yeah if
you haven't played Apex there's a lot of
povs going on it's like how do you you
know I think any Battle Royale or any
kind of shooter well and that's that's
what I feel about firstperson Shooters
as a whole in terms of like uh an
Esports I mean Counter-Strike is still
like one of the biggest Esports but I
still always think it's harder to follow
having so many different perspectives
than just yeah the perspective swapping
is the perspective that's true they they
added the Buster sword into the game so
you can just go around and like slash
people up it's cool it's kind of cool
cool I think it's actually ended by the
time that this episode's out but it was
pry cool wait yeah cuz I saw I saw so
many uh ads of it in like Arab dude they
was everywhere they went crazy so weird
just seeing like what was it it was
cloud tfer and aith right yeah they but
like they looked so different well cuz
it was like I think they didn't want to
do like a fortnite where they're like
Tia's in Apex yeah that would be a bit
weird they were like let's make one of
the characters kind of dressed like them
and it's kind of like if more so if the
character was cosplay yeah yeah cuz I
didn't even recognize like the
characters at first yeah cuz it just
looks completely a bar skin it looks
really cool though there's a yeah okay I
think Barrett probably out of all the
Final Fantasy 7 characters probably
works the best yeah he looks that stuff
cuz he's already a gun he's already got
a [__] gun he's already a gunman in
the game right so yeah but I think that
character doesn't use a gun for
[Music]
NS so he's carrying a gun I'm not I'm
actually not sure I think uh yeah but
then there was also like material bar
just has arms now apparently yeah and
there's also material you can pick up in
the game oh really like there's like the
little mascot that will follow you
around dressed as Cloud Lochness Monster
dressed as Cloud that shoot people it's
really funny it's it's really cool but
yeah it's a cool collaboration that's so
that's why I missed the company thing
which Joey went to right how was it it
was really fun uh we all we all went up
to Nago uh to this place called kamisu
uh and it's basically just kind of this
uh big lake that they have in n
I didn't know what we were going to be
do at first but I assumed it was just
going to be a chill thing um I I didn't
realize until we went on this trip and I
saw how many people came with us that
I'm like wow this company is really
[__] grown yeah cuz you didn't come
to the Christmas party did you you
missed the Christmas party I missed the
Christmas party but so I came to this
one and there were a lot of new faces I
hadn't seen before and I'm just like are
these all our stuff like this this is
way too many like three three four years
ago it was just us three and me yeah you
know and now it's like now there was
like how many people was a freelancer I
I was a freeler yeah you a freelancer k
hadn't joined us yet so many people had
joined us I think there was like 28
people yeah showed up to his name yeah I
think we the office was Denny's at that
point yeah it the office was Denny
that's why we had our meetings it was us
three me and the boss man at Denny's
that would that would remember our it's
it's I always love going to like company
events and just seeing how Meen acts now
because she just like you remember how
she was at the beginning and the way she
is now big boss now yeah all she does is
just stand in the corner and just look
happy seeing her children just interact
with each other and I don't know if she
was like that at the company party she
was definitely like that at the
Christmas party where she just people
watched oh yeah was like H H yes
children yes gather around gather around
talk to each other she was like Olma
looking over her Pikmin you know she
just like all right everyone gather
around here we go yeah so she did she
doesn't specifically do speeches but for
that one instance during I missed the me
speech man she did a speech and then
Masa did a whole rugo
section so so to explain we have we have
like a domestic guy at like Japanese guy
called Masa really cool dude uh but he I
I guess like studies a doore um and so
he was like you want to explain what
rock Roo is basically kind of like um
you know anecdotal standup but in a very
traditional Japanese sty Trad um it's
really good like Rocko Shinju amazing if
you watch that you'll understand it but
it's really difficult to do especially
well uh and so Masa you know being the
typical Japanese man getting drunk off
of one glass of beer was just red in the
face and after the speech everyone
someone mentioned was just like Mara do
some Rocko cuz there was kind of like a
stage uh in where we were having the
dinner and Mar was like all right fine
he jumps up just immediately gets into
it just off the top of the dome for like
15 minutes does this whole just like
Freestyle Rocko and it was so funny and
and everyone was just like all right all
right he can spit he's he's he can do
rugo and it was really really cool um
but yeah we got absolutely shitfaced
that night um I'm so I'm so sad the the
topic you mentioned in Rak as well was
pretty interesting oh yeah yeah yeah was
the topic you mentioned what was the
topic Pokémon animal abuse Pokémon
animal
abuse wait wait there's a Rocko skit for
Pokémon animal well no there isn't Mara
made it up on the spot so he he he came
up with the theme on the spot told this
whole story about like Pokémon did you
do in Japanese or in Japanese uh and
like he and he came up with like a
proper punch line and everything and
everyone was like oh that was a really
good bit how long have you been working
on that and M was like I just made that
up so Japanese man has one aah and he's
like a he unlocks 100% of his
brain but yeah and then we and then we
had like a little karaoke uh room uh in
the dean that we booked out uh until way
past everything I think I drank like
half a bottle of whiskey that night uh I
was pretty I was pretty hammered pretty
shitfaced pretty shitfaced but uh it was
fun it was fun I heard about the daon
incident what's the daon incident okay
so it was after the it was after the
whole uh karaoke thing right yeah so we
had the room till about originally we
had the room till about 11:00 p.m. but
once 11:00 p.m. hit we were all still
going really hard cuz we're all [__]
face so somebody called up the the room
and like convinced them to give us the
room till 12 instead but then after 12
we had to go back to our rooms by the
time we all went back to our rooms we
were very very drunk um I think it was
Kai and a couple of other people staff
were like oh let's go do a Comin run so
we so they went down to the comin to buy
what I thought was drinks cuz I stayed
in the room instead uh Cory one of the
staff members came back holding this the
biggest dyon that I've ever seen in my
life like I'm like dcon is radish by the
way this white radish that was probably
about this long and about this thick
really thick m and he just walked into
the room just holding it like a baseball
bat W and I was like Cory did you get M
drinks and he was like oh no but I got
you this dieon and and he just gave me
this massive D I'm like you can't do
[__] with the D and I'm like Cory what
do you want me to do with this and he
was like it was really cheap I was like
I don't care you didn't get me my drinks
so we were just drinking hanging out I
was sharing a room with um with Manu
Ohara yeah and uh you know they were in
the they were in the background with
dius playing Magic um and uh and Cory
said all right well we got to do
something about this daon I'm not taking
you back to my room and I'm like well
I'm
not all right well you bought it men
buys a d refuses to take it home you
bought it oh my God what am I going to
do with it and then uh Jordan one of our
new staff members was just like oh you
know what would be really funny and he
grabbed the D on and he slipped it
underneath uh O'Hara's pillow cuz we all
had like cuz we all had uh futons the
most like boys trip kind of like girls
are like I bet he's cheating on me boys
are like what do we do with the d The
Almighty dieon so he like he slipped it
under uh manu's pillow without him
realizing and then we we took bets we
were like let's see how long it takes
for him to notice that there's a giant
[__] D on under his pillow woke up
the next morning man hadn't noticed at
all until I told him about it I was like
you should flip over your pillar and he
flipped it over the next morning and he
was like the [__] is this so he slept on
a radish the whole night slept on a
radish the whole night and then he said
and the dead ass looked me in the eyes
and he went oh that's why my pillow was
rolling around all
night Ain no way he like legitimately
did but I think but then I was like was
it not uncomfortable and you know cuz
you you'd notice if you were sleeping on
a massive sleep on a godamn Rish and man
unironically he was just like oh no like
I actually really liked the pillow
height like it was it was actually kind
was going to go home and be like babe I
got to sleep with the
I can't get to sleep without my rsh babe
I just discovered this thing just hear
me out okay Tik Tock life hack Japan
life sleep with a radish H it is
customary to sleep with a radish in
Japan this this sounds like the Japanese
equivalent of you know like British and
Aussie piss heads when they come home
with like a traffic cone or some [__] in
Japan you just come back with a massive
R come back with a 50 dieon but uh we
are going to have a little bit of a
detour mhm because we are going to have
the first official ever trash taste
sponsored segments which we normally
wouldn't agree to is it the first one
we've done yeah I think this is the
first time we've ever been first time
we've ever done this damn all right uh
which we wouldn't normally agree to uh
but I guess Atlas came to us was it
Atlas that came to us specifically Sager
and Atlas Seer and Atlas uh so Sager and
Atlas came to us and said do you want to
talk about Persona 3 uh for 10 15
minutes however much you want to talk
about it and we were like well we were
going to do that anyway yeah i c i